monaco un terrain de jeu prisé par les
ultra riches avec segat luxueux son
casino légendaire ses banques privées sa
fiscalité avantageuse et bien sûr son
grand prix de formule 1
c'est dans cet univers que le coureur
automobile québécois jacques villeneuve
à ces quelques escales
son parcours extraordinaire l'amener au
sommet de la gloire lui permettant
d'accumuler une fortune considérable
c'était un contrat de 100 millions $
c'est un des athlètes les ailiers les
mieux payés les dents sont dans son
domaine
mais comme bien des sportifs de haut
niveau jacques villeneuve a effectué de
nombreux passages dans des paradis
fiscaux
grâce aux fondeurs rappeuse une nouvelle
fuite de documents confidentiels obtenus
par le consortium international des
journalistes d' enquêtes dont
radio-canada et partenaires nous avons
pu retracer le parcours fiscal de
jacques villeneuve un parcours parsemé
de virages qui lui ont permis d'éviter
fils depuis les tout débuts
[Musique]
c'est au coeur des paysages enchanteurs
des alpes suisses que se retrouve le
jeune jacques villeneuve à la suite de
la mort de son père le coureur
automobile gilles villeneuve
fait ses études secondaires au tracé des
collèges alpes un beau soleil à villars
sur ollon et grandi dans un
environnement
privilégié n'étudie pas au collège
beausoleil qui veut probablement l'école
secondaire la plus prestigieuse de la
planète je pense que le reconnaître le
ont grandi sa forge à peu notre notre
vision du monde
c'est là qu'il rencontre fred pollock un
professeur d'éducation physique qui
jouera un rôle clé dans la future
carrière de villeneuve en devenant son
gérant c'était le professeur de ski de
jacques au collège j'imagine un homme
doté d'un fort talent de persuasion
parce qu'il réussit à miami sa carrière
d'enseignant de côté pour pour aider a
lancé jacques dans le dans le milieu de
la course automobile
en 1992 jacques villeneuve compétition
au japon mais il fait un saut au québec
au mode ou ici établira en permanence
put an après
participent au grand prix de
trois-rivières en formule atlantique où
il finit en troisième position à l'âge
de 21 ans avec son gérant il apprend
aussi à manoeuvrer dans les paradis
fiscaux dès le début de sa carrière
mois plus tard à des milliers de
kilomètres de trois rivières dans le
paradis fiscal des bahamas une société
appelée constant court discours est
incorporé cette société portefeuille
sera utilisé par jacques villeneuve pour
recueillir ses revenus de compétition
posteront ding s'est elle même détenue
par une fiducie situé aux îles vierges
britanniques
un autre paradis fiscal des caraïbes où
le taux d'imposition est nul selon ce
document confidentiel provenant des
pandora paper cette fiducie a été mis
sur pied pour préserver gérer et
protéger les avoirs familiaux de
monsieur craig pollock et le monsieur
jacques villeneuve le recours aux
paradis fiscaux n'est pas illégal en soi
mais il peut priver les états de revenus
considérables selon eduardo traversable
professeur en droit fiscal à
l'université de louvain le sportif ne
devra plus payer des impôts sur les
revenus qu'il perçoit au travers de
sociétés dans son état de résidence par
exemple le canada mais que ses revenus
seront soumis au régime fiscal
de l'état où est située la société donc
par exemple les bahamas qui veut dire
alors une imposition
nul ou extrêmement extrêmement faible et
en tout cas bien plus favorable qu'au
canada
à partir de 1993 jacques villeneuve
compétitionne sur des circuits
nord-américain en formule atlantique sa
carrière par sur des chapeaux de roue
fermin recrue de l'année encore une fois
deuxième aux légendaires 500 milles
d'indianapolis remporté les 500 milles
d'indianapolis à peu par la suite et
l'autre c'est sûr que les gens de la
france sont tout de suite intéressé à
jacques villeneuve
pendant ces années sur le circuit nord
américain ses revenus grimpent en flèche
il récolte 10 millions de dollars
puis en 1996 les portes de l'univers
sacro-saint du circuit de formule 1
s'ouvre enfin pour le pilote québécois
jacques villeneuve des ménages à monaco
avec en poche un contrat de deux ans
avec l'écurie williams le chroniqueur
martin leclerc couvert la carrière de
jacques villeneuve en formule 1 pour le
journal de montréal jake habiter à
monaco à partir du moment où il est
devenu pilote de f1 c'est ce que la
plupart des pilotes de formule 1 faisait
à l'époque ils font encore aujourd'hui
le s'éteint c'est un endroit où il n'ya
pas d'impôt à payer en plus et on en
voit qui est bien localisé pour
se transporter d'un grand prix à l'eau
ça monte sur le circuit de formule 1 est
fulgurante
en 1997 après un duel mémorable avec
michael schumacher
le championnat de formule 1 à l'âge de
26 ans
[Musique]
voici le voici
l'un voit ses vignes devient un héros
national ils québec lui réserve un
accueil spectaculaire hausse entre mosna
montréal même si j'ai grandi en europe
mais mes sources sont canadiennes sont
québécoises et ça ça changera jamais
et sa fortune elle continue de gonfler
quand on remporte le championnat du
monde on devient automatiquement des
piles un des pilotes les mieux payés du
paddock c'était certainement supérieure
à 15 millions $ par saison la nouvelle
golf l'aiment bien c'est pas de la
chanteuse ils ont plus des salaires et
des bourses les vedettes sportives de
haut niveau perçoivent aussi des revenus
substantiels grâce à leur droit à
l'image il peut s'agir de contrats de
publicité avec différentes sociétés
commerciales il peut s'agir de droits de
retransmission télévisée
cela a peut être l'essentiel la toute
grande majorité
de des revenus annuels du sportif quand
on pense à des à des super stars
planétaires comme un cristiano ronaldo
comme rodger federer donc il s'agit de
sommes qui peuvent être très
considérable
et bien souvent les vedettes sportives
transfèrent leur droit à l'image à des
société incorporée dans des paradis
fiscaux selon un document confidentiel
une nouvelle société villeneuve
multimédia est incorporé aux bahamas en
1998 l'actionnaire principal et ghost
world inc l'autre société créée aux
bahamas pour jacques villeneuve
villeneuve multimédia percevra ses
droits d'image dans le domaine des jeux
vidéo de course automobile
andré lareau et professeur associé en
droit fiscal à l'université laval ce que
si on me coupait un drop andy temps
brand va s'en aller en pays étranger les
revenus gagnés par tombera finalement
neutre appartiendront pas ça tient pas à
la notion de droit à l'image ce droit-là
m'appartient alors je suis capable par
une fiction de la loi de transférer les
revenus qui proviendront de ma de mon
nom de mon image de ce qui m'appartient
à moi dans mon cerveau je capable
transférer ce revenu à l'extérieur c'est
hallucinant mais c'est permis
quelques années plus tard ubisoft publie
le jeu vidéo speed challenge jacques
villeneuve racing les jeunes avec
l'autorisation de gaulle store holding
la vie professionnelle de jacques
villeneuve et elle prend un virage
inattendu
il décide de faire le saut vers une
nouvelle écurie brrr qui est dirigé par
son gérant craig pollock villeneuve
signe lucratif contrat de 20 millions de
dollars par année se sont lancés avec
des budgets presque illimitées mais ça a
été un flop
monumental c'est difficile d'avoir du
succès rapidement en f1 et il a été là
on a suivi à partir de ce moment là un
peu le déclin de la carrière de jean
villeneuve il se battait comme un diable
nova là d'une poubelle alors ils
pouvaient pas et pouvait pas remporter
des courses malheureusement
malgré ses déboires sur la piste de
course jacques villeneuve continue de
vivre la vie de multimillionnaires à
monaco à bord d'un luxueux iap de plus
de 40 mètres le glisse en 2002 le blessé
est immatriculée au luxembourg un pays
d'europe sans accès aux océans mais aux
règles fiscales avantageuses
à cette époque son gérant craig pollock
continue de gérer sa vie professionnelle
et sa vie privée la vie privée ça peut
être des bateaux des avions des les
maisons à gauche et à droite et puis
tout ce qu'il veut dans la vie privée
c'est qu'on a en trop dancers qui est
derrière nasri congé qui arrivent il
faut qu'il ya quelqu'un là pour
l'accueillir et puis même qu'il ya de
l'est et puis du pain dans le frigo il
faut tu sois fait dans un point de
presse vous avez nous avait dit qu'il
savait même pas combien avaient d'argent
à la banque que c'est que c'est greg qui
s'occupait de tous les aspects
financiers la gestion de son argent tout
ça ça nous avait ça nous avait beaucoup
surpris la table seulement on sait à peu
près combien on a d'argent là bas et lui
disait avoir aucune idée malgré le fait
que c'est un pilote qui est qu'ils
avaient un des mieux payés du paddock la
formule 1 c'est un petit cirque qui fait
le tour du monde c'est un groupe de gens
fortunés qui se considèrent comme des
citoyens du monde qui on dirait qu'ils
prennent le meilleur de ce qu'ils ont à
prendre un peu partout et qui quittèrent
tous les bénéfices possibles
en 2002 jacques villeneuve retourne en
suisse à villars sur ollon le même
village où il avait fait ses études
la suisse offre aux vedettes sportives
qui viennent s'y établir un forfait
fiscal avantageux
la même année dans les caraïbes une
autre fiducie est créé pour le coureur
automobile québécois selon la fuite des
pandora paper la fiducie glion trust est
établie aux îles vierges britanniques en
novembre 2002 pour préserver gérer
protéger les avoirs familiaux de
monsieur jacques villeneuve
après la fin de son contrat avec paris9
vend son yatch qui lui coûte une fortune
en frais de fonctionnement
puis s'ils signent un contrat de
plusieurs millions de dollars avec
l'écurie bmw sauber
mais vers la fin de ce contrat en 2006
il sent les portes du monde la formule 1
se refermer
peu de temps après jacques villeneuve a
quitté le confort les avantages fiscaux
de son chalet alpin pour retourner vivre
au québec
vous
[Musique]
après avoir vécu dans des paradis
fiscaux européens jusqu'en 2007 jacques
villeneuve effectué un retour à montréal
pour tenter sa chance sur le circuit
nord-américain de courses automobiles
nascar
je pense qu'ils essayaient de
donner une nouvelle tournure à sa
carrière de se relancer quand tu obtiens
des contrats de quelques courses en
nascar le cnpa pour des millions mais
qu'en même temps ceux ci le nom de 2009
jacques villeneuve s'installe rue
saint-pierre dans le vieux montréal dans
un luxueux penthouse de deux étages qui
compte une immense terrasse privée avec
vue imprenable sur le centre ville le
propriétaire du condo est une société
appelée saffer blue golding qui est
incorporé aux îles vierges britanniques
un document lié à la vente du condo
quelques années plus tard montre que
c'est jacques villeneuve kiss-in pour
safari bluewings il a donc utilisé une
société des caraïbes pour acheter et
vendre de l'immobilier à montréal
c'est que ce villeneuve préféré que son
nom apparaisse nulle part et donc en
ayant une société des îles vierges
britanniques
son nom était plus difficilement
repérables mais davantage penser si la
question de avait des sommes disponibles
dans cette société
juste avant son retour au québec jacques
villeneuve fait aussi l'achat d'un
immense domaine de 8 150 acres dans les
laurentides sur lequel il va construire
un imposant chalet en bois rond mais sur
papier l'actionnaire da société qui se
porte acquéreur du terrain est classé
toile s à une société incorporée au
luxembourg un paradis fiscal
puis en janvier 2007 jacques villeneuve
fait l'acquisition d'un manoir de 3
millions de dollars sur la rue sunny
side à westmount en plus d'être
effectué d'importantes rénovations de
près de six millions de dollars qui font
l'objet d'une vidéo promotionnelle
la résidence des villeneuve compte 22
pièces dont cinq chambres sept salles de
bain et une cave à vin
pendant qu'il vit à montréal jacques
villeneuve se trouve régulièrement au
chic resto bar newton qu'il a ouvert en
2001 sur la rue crescent
[Musique]
de près branché l'époque mais c'était
une des boîtes populaire à montréal les
gens qui écrivent des montréal et
touristes ce avec le newton c'était
l'établissement de jacques villeneuve
mais sur papier l'actionnaire principale
du restaurant n'est pas jacques
villeneuve mais plutôt flatteur
investments une société incorporée aux
bahamas
[Musique]
aujourd'hui de musique
en plus du domaine de la restauration
jacques villeneuve tente aussi de lancer
une nouvelle carrière de chanteur
[Musique]
on
dans les mois qui précèdent son retour
au canada il convoque la presse
montréalaise pour le lancement d'une
chanson il dévoilera plus tard un album
complet intitulé private paradise
l'incursion en musée comme ça pas été un
succès le même les critiques je pense à
assez démoli cet album là mais
il y avait la liberté et le luxe de se
lancer dans des aventures comme celle là
parce que
parce qu'il avait les moyens de le faire
et vous visez qualcomm vente qu'est ce
qui vous ferait plaisir aucune idée ça
vous importe non non c'est j'aurais été
content juste de l'imprimé puis de
donner à des amis aussi donc c'est pas
c'est pas vrai c'est vraiment pas une
étude de marché qui a été fait à peine
deux mois avant cette entrevue une autre
société dit à jacques villeneuve album
holding limited a été incorporé aux
bahamas en avril 2006 selon la fédé
pandora paper album holding sa est une
société de portefeuille détenant des
brevets et des droits d'auteur des
actionnaires de cette société sont deux
fiducie l'une dié à jacques villeneuve
et l'autre à son gérant de l'époque
craig pollock
jacques villeneuve va-t-il conserver ces
sociétés et sa fiducie des caraïbes
lorsqu'il est devenu un résident
canadien en 2007 à partir du moment où
jacques villeneuve devient résident à la
fiducie elles par des règles fiscales
applicables à ce moment-là deviez
résidente du canada et doit payer des
impôts au québec et au canada sur les
revenus qu'elle gagne
ni jacques villeneuve ne craque pollock
n'ont répondu à nos questions depuis
2008 jacques villeneuve fait cavalier
seul après avoir rompu sa relation
professionnelle avec pollock
dans une entrevue accordée à la presse
en 2013 villeneuve a affirmé avoir
respecté les règles fiscales de tous les
pays où il est passé il a déclaré alors
qu'il était très important pour lui de
ne jamais avoir de squelettes cacher et
qu'au canada il avait perdu beaucoup
d'argent en impôts ou autrement
en arrivant au québec jacques villeneuve
se départit de ses intérêts dans la
société costard building dans les années
suivantes certains autres de ses
sociétés des caraïbes commencent à
disparaître ou deviennent inactive
en 2010 cependant qu'il est toujours au
québec jacques villeneuve est encore en
lien avec le cabinet d'avocats qui a mis
sur pied plusieurs de ses sociétés dans
les caraïbes selon le document
confidentiel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2012 le fameux printemps érable
school québec et jacques villeneuve va
se retrouver au coeur de la contreverse
des étudiants manifestent pendant des
mois contre la hausse des frais de
scolarité annoncée par le gouvernement
libéral de jean charest
gabriel nadeau dubois était un porte
parole du mouvement étudiant à l'époque
l'objectif de ce fait avoir cette
affaire en tente de montrer qu'on existe
et qu'on était toujours debout tel
gouvernement devait écouter nos
revendications
les négociations entre les étudiants et
le gouvernement sont dans l'impasse les
jeunes décident alors de perturber des
événements liés au grand prix de
montréal afin de faire bouger les choses
c'est sûr que le grand prix c'est pas
exactement leur 2ème du projet de
société qu'on défende en 2012 en sont un
événement très polluants qui rassemblent
souvent la crème de la crème de l'élite
politique et économique
[Musique]
lors du chic cocktail d'ouverture du
grand prix le gratin de la formule 1 et
des vedettes québécoises font leur
apparition sur le tapis rouge y compris
jacques villeneuve c'est un petit peu
dommage
qu'ils aient ces problèmes lance en ce
moment mais j'espère que le week-end va
quand même bien se dérouler qu'on n'aura
pas trop de problèmes j'ai l'impression
que ça pue la ceni marque je suis des
étrangers une marque très négative oui
c'est vraiment pas bon du tout ce qui se
passe c'est donc il y obtient un petit
manque de réflexion qui se fait de la
part d'un paquet de jeunes individus
villeneuve en rajoutent pour la presse
anglophone
ne sais pas ce qu to make sense puis il
se vide le coeur devant des journalistes
de radio
ça coûte cher à tout le monde je pense
qu'ils ont passé leur jeunesse à grandir
sans que aux cinq heures par an leur
dise non jamais donc c'est sûr qu'on
voit même maintenant dans les russes sa
part sont pas se plaindre et c'est
oublier tant que les gens seraient bien
tu peux qui
des raids de faire des finales
vous avez réagi
je me rappelle je me rappelle qu'on me
montre l'extrême honnêtement je
mentirais si je disais que j'étais
surpris où on a décidé de se doter de
services publics la santé l'éducation
mais même les routes sur lesquelles
roulent les voitures de f1 tout ça est
payé avec des fonds publics cet
argent-là
faut qu'il faut que tout le monde
contribue à la caisse commune i les gens
qui en ont plus doivent contribuer plus
alors moi ça me surprend pas de savoir
qu'un multimillionnaire comme jacques
villeneuve
méprise un mouvement social dont
l'objectif à terme c'est mieux répartir
la richesse
à la suite de la sortie controversée de
jacques villeneuve journaliste martin
leclerc publie sur le site de radio
canada une chronique intitulée le monde
selon jacques villeneuve
je m'attendais pas à voir jacques
pharand virage par virage à gauche parce
que
durant les années où je les ai côtoyés
en f1 si quelqu'un m'avait semblé quand
même assez
adroit et quand même particulier de voir
quelqu'un qui a étudié au collège
beausoleil en suisse un des collèges du
plus prestigieux au monde où les 4
vérités sont peut-être 100 mille dollars
par année à l'époque et de le voir
critiquer comme ça un débat sur la sur
l'accessibilité scolaire
dans les mois qui suivent jacques
villeneuve décide qu'il en a ras-le-bol
du québec et son team à social ludique
était très déçu a cité ses
manifestations étudiantes
dans la liste des déceptions qui l'avait
par rapport au québec il avait dit au
québec est enfin devenu comme la france
des revendications sociales les
critiques des étudiants et souhaite m'en
veut toujours plus et ça me déçoit
beaucoup donc je préfère aller
m'installer
ailleurs et je quitte le québec
ait choisi de s'établir en europe dans
la minuscule principauté d'andorre
située entre la france et l'espagne une
explication potentiel que j'appuie
l'avem bien les les pyrénées les sports
d'hiver une autre heure pourrait être
andorre est un pays qui est connue pour
son climat fiscal
favorable
andorre jusqu'en 2014 il me semble avec
un système extrêmement favorable parce
qu'il ne connaissait pas d'impôt sur le
revenu une hypocrisie et nord t2 de
rapprocher d'un côté
à des à des jeunes de se mobiliser pour
une société plus juste et de l'autre
fuir ses responsabilités à l'égard de la
société
en allant s'établir dans un paradis
fiscal pour surtout éviter surtout oh
mon dieu la tragédie qui représenterait
le fait de contribuer au bien commun
dans une entrevue accordée au journal de
montréal en 2013 il nie s'être établie à
andorre pour des raisons fiscales il dit
que son départ n'est pas une question
d'impôts et affirme avoir payé ses
impôts pendant ses cinq années passées
au québec
en 2013 le coureur automobile jacques
villeneuve s'installe dans le paradis
fiscal d'andorre après avoir quitté
québec mais il se retrouve rapidement
avec le fisc québécois à ses trousses
revenu québec lui demande des comptes
afin de vérifier s'il a déclaré tous ses
revenus mondiaux pendant ses années de
résidence au québec
il doit fournir aux autorités fiscales
la liste de ces biens à l'étranger mais
villeneuve tarder à remettre les
documents demandés et omet de mentionner
l'existence d'un compte bancaire en
suisse les contribuables résidents
canadiens doivent divulguer les comptes
à l'étranger dans la mesure où il existe
nous sommes bons supérieurs à 100 mille
dollars dans ses comptes le défaut
d'avoir effectivement obtempéré à cette
question fait en sorte que la relation
le contribuable est revenu québec pour
être un peu plus tendue selon revenu
québec jacques villeneuve n'aurait pas
justifier la provenance et la nature de
multiples dépôts dans ses comptes à la
banque hsbc de montréal une autre somme
en litige est un prêt de 300 mille
dollars provenant de couche-tard holding
une des nombreuses sociétés incorporé
pour villeneuve dans les bahamas
jacques villeneuve contestent devant les
tribunaux les conclusions de revenu
québec ses avocats soutiennent qu'ils
n'avaient pas à déclarer ces sommes car
ce nom et elles n'étaient pas imposables
parmi les documents soumis au tribunal
par jacques villeneuve se trouvent ces
déclarations de revenus en 2010 il a
déclaré à titre personnel un maigre
revenu de quelque 6400 dollars
selon le formulaire le multi
millionnaire aurait aussi réclamé le
crédit d'impôt pour la solidarité
un crédit d'impôt qui vise à venir en
aide aux familles québécoises à faible
revenu
jacques villeneuve a refusé de répondre
à nos questions
son avocat montréalais martin delisle
indique qu'il ne souhaite faire aucun
commentaire en raison des procédures
judiciaires en cours
selon lui québec jacques villeneuve a
déclaré des revenus à titre personnel de
3224 dollar en 2011 et 2,5 1780 du
dollar en 2012 parce que son ami devait
valoir puisque seuls trois médias je
vais tout le monde sait que jacques
villeneuve a pas fait 3000 $ dans ces
années là il est tout à fait possible
de percevoir un montant très faible de
revenu à titre personnel tout en
percevant au travers de différentes
sociétés des sommes beaucoup plus
importantes
en effet une société incorporée au
québec pour jacques villeneuve vie
course newton a recueilli plus d'un
million $ en revenus de course
automobile et en contrats publicitaires
selon les états financiers déposés à la
cour et la payer des impôts de 27 mille
dollars en 2013 mais elle a déclaré des
pertes les trois années précédentes et
n'aurait donc eu aucun impôt à payer ces
années là est ce que jacques villeneuve
va respecter la lettre de la loi je pars
fiscalisme c'est possible il ya des
stratagèmes fiscaux et de l'évitement
fiscal qui peut pas être légal ça ne
rend pas légitime et encore moins
socialement acceptable on seulement
d'après pour qu'on attend dans l'est
dans les hôpitaux pourquoi il ya passé
l'autobus pourquoi les écoles tombe en
ruine pourquoi les il n'y a pas d'eau
potable dans les réserves autochtones
le recours répandu de stratégies
d'évitement fiscal dans l'univers des
sportifs de haut niveau pose un
important problème d'éthique à l'échelle
mondiale selon le professeur edwards ou
traversa mais je crois qu'on assiste un
problème qui est l'équivalent de celui
du dopage mais d'un point de vue fiscal
à partir du moment où ces sportifs de
haut niveau sont aussi des personnes qui
serve d'exemple à des millions de fans à
travers le monde cela mine le contrat
social dans la mesure où des personnes
qui ont des revenus bien moindre ce 10
mai s'ils lui le fait pourquoi est ce
que moi je devrais le payer
après quelques années passées dans la
principauté d'andorre jacques villeneuve
est retourné vivre dans les alpes
suisses pour finalement s'installer en
italie dans une résidence de lombardie
l'italie aussi offre un alléchant
forfait fiscal pour les riches étrangers
qui viennent s'y établir
[Musique]
e
je
[Musique]